-Our first guest tonight is
a Grammy Award-winning musician,
multi-platinum recording artist,
and actor.
He stars in "X,"
which is in theaters
nationwide this Friday,
March 18th.
Let's take a look.
♪♪
-Sorry to bother you, ma'am,
but my van broke down
on the highway back yonder,
and I was hoping
I could use y'all's phone
to call for help.
-Oh, my goodness.
I'm afraid
we don't own a telephone,
but my daddy will be home soon,
and I'm sure he could
give you a lift to town.
Would you like to come inside?
♪♪
-Much obliged.
-Please welcome to the show
Kid Cudi, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show!
-What's good?
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They're very happy you're here.
I'm very happy you're here.
I do --
That's a fantastic clip,
but I feel like what we showed
just makes it look like
an adult film from the '70s.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
-But this is a horror film
about making an adult film
in the '70s that then,
a lot of stuff goes wrong.
-Yeah, it gets wild.
-And it looks beautiful!
Like, is -- it's so fun to watch
a sort of period piece
that's also a horror film,
and it just looks great,
the whole film.
-Yeah, Ti is just a genius,
and he had a vision.
And, you know,
as soon as I got this e-mail
about this project, I jumped
at the opportunity, you know?
-It has a great location
for a horror movie,
which I think
is such a key to it.
-Yeah.
-It's like, sort of, an old,
rundown farm.
Obviously, when you're filming
a horror movie, it's not
as scary as watching it.
But are you --
as you're making it,
do you think,
"Oh, this is gonna
freak people out
when they see it"?
-Yeah, like, every so often,
you have a project
that you're working on,
and you feel,
while you're in it, that you're
making something special.
And I really felt that
with this movie.
You know?
And there were some scenes --
It wasn't, like, scary for me,
because this is
my first horror movie,
so I don't know how it is.
But I wasn't really scared,
but there was this one scene
where we were out in the woods,
and it was, like, late at night.
It was like 1:00 in the morning,
and I was look,
"Ooh, this is cool."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm doing, like,
classic horror-movie scene.
I'm, like, in the woods.
It's creepy.
I'm walking by myself.
Anything could happen.
Anything could happen!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, but it was exciting,
'cause, like,
I'm a huge horror fan.
-And you started
watching them very young.
-Very young, man.
-So how old were you
when you started watching?
-I think my first horror movie
was 7-years-old.
-Okay.
-But I had older siblings,
'cause, like,
they were always playing stuff,
and I would be curious to see
what they were watching.
But I think my first horror
movie that I ever watched
was "Night of the Living Dead,"
and then "Evil Dead,"
and then Freddy Krueger, like,
they were all around
the same time.
-And were someone who --
were you the kind of kid
who then had nightmares, or did
you just have the joy of horror?
Was it just entertainment?
-I had nightmares.
I enjoyed being scared.
-Yeah.
-You know, like --
You know, I don't know,
it was just something about it.
You know?
It's just like,
I guess why people like
to get on roller coasters.
-Yeah.
-You know, it's just like,
you like putting yourself
through the thrill
of being scared.
-And now you're a father,
as well.
-Yes.
-Do you let your child --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
She's old -- how old is --
how old's your daughter?
-My daughter will be 12
in a couple of weeks.
-All right, and now,
were you protective of her?
No horror movies for her?
-No, see --
See, here's the thing, Seth.
-Okay, I'm very excited
about this.
-When I had my child...
-Uh-huh.
-...I thought about
all the things
I could mold her to be,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Like, video games, for example.
-Okay.
-I wanted her to be a gamer.
-Oh, interesting.
-So, like, I put like all these
"Mario Kart" decorations
in her room, like, strategically
so she would be a gamer.
-Gotcha.
-And, so horror movies --
-I feel like that's not a thing
you have to push kids towards.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know,
I was just, like, worried.
Maybe she might not be into it,
so I wanted to make sure.
You know what I'm saying?
-Right, right.
Lock it in, yep.
-Because, like, I want to play
"Call of Duty Zombies"
with someone.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
So I had her watching
horror movies when she was 8.
She was really curious,
and I was like, "Okay.
I think you're old enough
to watch something," right?
-Uh-huh.
-So I think "It"
came out at that time.
-Okay.
[ Audience groans ]
-Well, they say --
-What?
-They say it --
[ Laughter ]
They say it right on the poster,
"Great for kids."
-I know!
And there's kids in it!
-Kids are in it.
-There's kids in it.
-It's important
to see yourself in art.
-Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
So, like,
you know, we watched "It."
And, you know,
I'm looking at her, like,
you know,
when Pennywise comes out,
I'm just watching her reaction.
And she's just like,
"Why they following that clown?"
[ Laughter ]
"Why they following
that balloon?
They're stupid.
They're stupid."
And I just love, like,
sitting with her,
because she has these
commentaries during the movies.
-Yeah.
-And she says the realest stuff.
It's just like,
"Yeah, I feel you, kid."
-Well, that's great.
As a father, it must be nice
to hear her think the kids
in "It" are stupid, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-The worst thing
is if she's like,
"Well, you gotta
follow the clown.
You can't blame them."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, my buddy -- my buddy Ivan
was telling me, he was like,
"Well, she's a Chicago kid.
She ain't no slouch."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
Like, it's cool, man.
I know she's not, like,
a chump out here.
-So you're an Ohioan,
and you actually
got to go to the Super Bowl.
You performed at the afterparty
for the Super Bowl.
-Yes, yes.
-And -- but you recently,
I guess, got to know
Joe Burrow a little bit.
-Yes.
-And, you know, a very --
a very cool operator.
The man knows what he's doing.
A very young man who's obviously
incredibly accomplished already.
And you reached out.
And how did this work?
You asked him for a jersey?
-Well, before the Chiefs game,
I reached out to him
and just told him good luck
and sent him a song to kind of
get him pumped up for the game.
And then, like, when they won --
-And this was one of your --
a preexisting song.
You didn't, like,
write him a new song.
-No, I wrote him a song.
I wrote him a love song.
[ Laughter ]
-I just like him in the locker
room being like, "Okay.
This is not what I --"
-Yeah, yeah!
And it was like...
♪ Joe, hello ♪
♪ You need to know
you got the glow, Joe ♪
It was something like that.
-I mean, obviously, it worked.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It worked!
-So they won the game
because of my song, you know?
-Yeah!
And then, obviously, you forgot
to do one for the Super Bowl.
-Yeah, I forgot --
I forgot, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I will say that, like,
I kind of -- I got bold,
and I was just like, "Man,
I'm just gonna go ahead
and ask him
for the jersey, man.
Like, I think maybe he might
want to keep it for himself,
but let me just
go ahead and ask."
And he literally responded
right away.
He's like,
"I'm sending it tomorrow."
-And now this is a game-worn
AFC Championship jersey.
-Yeah.
-And let me tell you,
that's got the right amount
of grime on it.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah!
It's got blood stains on it.
It's real in the gridiron.
-Everything about it
is outstanding.
-Yeah.
-I really think that's a --
that's a great thing.
A great piece of sports
memorabilia for you to have.
So this is very exciting.
I think you're new friends
with our next guest, Quinta.
-Yes.
-And she is coming out.
She's got a fantastic show,
"Abbott Elementary."
-Yes, she does.
-You're a fan of this show?
-Yes, yes, yes.
-You'd like to maybe even
be on this show.
-Yeah.
And that was something that
I was kind of just
throwing out with --
talking to Tyler about.
-Tyler, one of the co-stars
on "Abbott," yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
And, you know,
I'm a big fan of teachers.
And --
Like, my mom was a teacher.
She was a music teacher
for 35 years.
She was actually
my music teacher.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-My mom was a French teacher
for about 30 years.
She was my French teacher.
-Wow!
-And I hate to say it,
but based on your music career
and my French career, I think
your mom was the better teacher.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know what?
We didn't say we were gonna
talk about this, but I'm gonna
just put this out there.
-Yeah.
-So this is --
My mom was my teacher
in the seventh grade, right?
And I was forced into her class,
because I knew
when I went to her school,
I was like, "All right.
I'm gonna have to either
be in her class or be in band,
and I don't want
to be in her class,
so I have to learn
how to play an instrument."
So, like, I picked the trumpet
because my older brother
played the trumpet,
and at that age, I was just,
like, trying to do anything
he was doing.
I was trying to be like him.
So I picked up the trumpet,
and then, like, I was failing
this class bad, right?
So, like, the teacher goes up
to my mom and he says,
"Hey, your son's not doing too
good in this class, you know?
And maybe you might
want to switch him out
and put him in choir."
So we switched me out,
and I got in choir, and, like,
all year long, I'm just, like,
in the back of the class,
trying not to get called on.
You know, and my mom was always
trying give me solos and [bleep]
Sorry, I cursed.
-That's all right.
[ Laughter ]
-So stressed out about that,
still, to this day.
[ Laughter ]
But report cards came,
the end of the year came,
and, like, I'm thinking like,
"Okay.
My mom is gonna give me
an A-plus."
You know, it's my --
it's my ma, right?
And I get my report card,
and I got a B-minus.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Like, my mom keeps it so real.
She was like,
"You missed some homework."
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"You keep it so funky.
I got to respect it."
-Well, absolutely.
You set a bar high
for your kids.
You got to do it.
-Yeah.
-You're gonna stick around.
We're gonna have you out here
for Quinta, as well.
That's Kid Cudi, everybody.
"X" is in theaters this Friday.
We'll be right back!